>> Tammy: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
NEW LETTER FROM REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS IS DEMANDING THAT
ADAM SCHIFF TESTIFY AS TO
HIS CONTACTS WITH THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLEBLOWER MORE
ON THAT JUST AHEAD.
FIRST TONIGHT WE ARE INCHING
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO TRUTH
AND JUSTICE AND HOLDING
THOSE THAT ABUSE POWER
ACCOUNTABLE.
GOING TO TAKE A WHILE
BECAUSE THERE IS SO MANY OF
THEM.
DUMB PROBE IS A FULL SCALE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THE HOROWITZ REPORT IS
EXPECTED TO BE OUT THIS
MONTH.
I KNOW WE WERE ALSO TOLD
THAT LAST MONTH.
HOPEFULLY WE WILL GET IT
THIS MONTH.
AND A DAY OF RECKONING IS ON
THE HORIZON FROM THE DEEP
STATE FROM THE RIGGED
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
CLINTON TO THE DIRTY STILL
DOSSIER UNTIL RAMPANT
EVIDENCE OF FISA ABUSE.
THE MEDIA MOB CONTINUES TO
IGNORE THE REAL 2016
ELECTION SCANDAL AND TONIGHT
WE ARE LEARNING EVEN MORE
ABOUT A MASSIVE MEDIA
SCANDAL BECAUSE JOURNALIST
LEE SMITH IN A NEW BOMBSHELL
BOOK HAS UNCOVERED MORE
EVIDENCE OF A POSSIBLE
PAY-TO-PUBLISH SCHEME
INVOLVING FUSION GPS AND
HIGH PROFILE REPORTERS.
AND AS OUR OWN GREGG JARRETT
POINT OUT THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLEBLOWER MAY EVEN BE
IMPLICATED IN THE UPCOMING
FISA REPORT DUE TO HIS
ALLEGED TIES TO JOHN BRENNAN
AND OTHERS.
NOW THE HYSTERIA WE SEE OVER
UKRAINE IS JUST THE LATEST
CHAPTER IN WHAT'S BEEN A
THREE-YEAR-LONG CAMPAIGN.
YOU GUYS, IT'S BEEN THAT
LONG.
THREE YEARS OF CONSTANT
LIES, SMEARS, BESMIRCHMENTS,
TO TAKE DOWN A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
IT IS A NEVER ENDING
IMPEACHMENT OBSESSION FROM
EVEN BEFORE I WOULD ARGUE,
BEFORE HIS ACTUAL ELECTION.
THIS IS NOW ABOUT
OVERTURNING THE RESULTS OF
THE 2016 ELECTION AND
OVERTURNING THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JOINING ME FOR REACTION
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
"WITCH-HUNT" FOX NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST GREGG JARRETT AND
ATTORNEY BRETT TOLLMAN AND
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK PLOT
AGAINST THE JOURNALIST
JOURNALIST LEE SMITH.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME TONIGHT.
GREG, LET ME START WITH YOU
WITH THIS NEWS ABOUT NUNES
SENDING THE LETTER SAYING WE
WANT TO YOU HAVE A WITNESS.
I FIND IT, OF COURSE,
TROUBLES BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS CAN VETO WHATEVER
REPUBLICANS WANT.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE.
>> IT UNFAIRNESS OF THIS.
CALL THE WITNESS, YOU HAVE
TO GET THE OTHER SIDES'
PERMISSION.
WHEN I TRIED CASES I DIDN'T
HAVE TO TURN TO THE
PROSECUTOR OR THE
PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEY AND SAY
MAY I PLEASE CALL MY FIRST
WITNESS?
NO, YOU MAY NOT.
SO, YOU KNOW, THE FIRST
WITNESS YOU WANT TO CALL
WOULD BE THE WHISTLEBLOWER.
SCHIFF WILL SAY DENIED I
WOULD LIKE YOU, MR. SCHIFF
TO TESTIFY.
DENIED.
I WOULD LIKE YOUR STAFF THAT
HAD CONTACT WITH THE
WHISTLEBLOWER.
DENIED.
THIS ANATHEMA TO FUND MENTAL
FAIRNESS AND DUE PROCESS.
IT DOES UNDERSCORE THAT AS
WELL AS THE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
THE GUY PRESIDING OVER THE
IMPEACHMENT HEARING IS A
FACT WITNESS HIMSELF?
CONCEAL HIS CONTACT WITH THE
WHISTLEBLOWER WHO IS NOT A
WHISTLEBLOWER UNDER THE LAW
THIS IS TERRIBLE.
>> Tammy: BRET WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SEEING.
FORGET ABOUT YOUR PARTY AND
PARTISANSHIP OR WHETHER YOU
LIKE TRUMP OR NOT.
THIS IS INHERENTLY UNFAIR
AMERICANS ARE WILLING TO
HAVE THIS INVESTIGATION
HAPPEN BUT THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO TRUST THE OUTCOME.
PROCESS IS THE THING THAT
LEADS US TO THE TRUTH.
SO WHEN WE HEAR ABOUT THIS
AND CLEARLY I THINK THE
REPUBLICANS WANT TO POINT
OUT THIS UNFAIRNESS AND THIS
REQUEST MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
THERE IS A CONFLICT AND OF
COURSE SCHIFF IS GOING TO
SAY NO, I'M NOT GOING TO DO
IT.
IT'S GOING TO HIGHLIGHT
THESE THINGS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IS THAT A LARGE PART OF WHAT
MATTERS HERE WHEN IT COMES
TO HOW THIS PLAYS OUT?
>> WELL, THIS IS AT THE
HEART AND I LOVE WHAT GREGG
SAID BECAUSE FAIRNESS AND DO
YOU PROCESS IS IMPORTANT IN
THIS PROCEDURE THAT IS GOING
FORWARD.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
NOT SEEING IT.
AS A PROSECUTOR, I REMEMBER
BEING TOLD AND TAUGHT
FASTEST WAY YOU CAN THROW
YOUR CASE OUT OF COURT IS IF
THE GOVERNMENT LOSES
CREDIBILITY.
IF THE GOVERNMENT CAN'T BE
TRUSTED.
WELL, HERE YOU HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT LAUNCHING AN
INVESTIGATION OF A SITTING
PRESIDENT BASED ON
SUSPICIOUS FACTS SURROUNDING
A WHISTLEBLOWER THAT APPEARS
TO BE POLITICALLY CONNECTED
AND THEN THEY LIE ABOUT
THEIR INTERACTIONS WITH THE
WHISTLEBLOWER.
FOR ME, THIS WOULD BE THE --
AN ABSOLUTE NIGHTMARE.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO TOUCH
THIS CASE WITH A 10-FOOT
POLE.
WHY ARE THEY EMBRACING IT?
BECAUSE THEY HAVE LOST AT
EVERY POINT UNTIL NOW.
AND AS YOU SAID, THEY HAVE
BEEN FOCUSED ON IMPEACHMENT
SINCE 2016.
>> Tammy: AND LEE,
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
BOOK.
WE ARE SEEING HERE AT THE
SAME TIME RANGING FROM THE
RUSSIA DOSSIER HOAX TO THIS,
THERE'S A -- NOT JUST THE
SLOPPINESS TO WHAT'S BEEN
DONE, BUT PEOPLE WHO EXPECT
NOT TO BE FOUND OUT BUT,
MOST OF ALL, THEY ALSO
EXPECT IT TO BE, YOU KNOW,
BACKED UP BY MEDIA.
THEY HAVE WORKED WITH MEDIA
THROUGH THIS PROCEDURE.
TELL US WHAT YOU THINK
BECAUSE WE HAVE GOT SO MANY
PEOPLE HEARSAY AND GOSSIP
AND RELIED ON NEWSPAPER
STORIES.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THAT
ELEMENT?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING BEFORE ABOUT THE
START OF THE BEFORE THE
ELECTION IS ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT IN MY BOOK I HAVE
DIFFERENT SOURCES WHO SHOW
DOCUMENTS AND SOURCES SHOW
THIS BEGAN IN MARCH OF 2016.
AND YOU SAW BEFORE THE
ELECTION YOU SAW A
COORDINATION BETWEEN CLINTON
OPERATIVES AND THE PRESS
THIS LASTED UNTIL THE
ELECTIONS.
AND THEN AFTER THE ELECTION,
CLINTON OPERATIVES WERE LESS
IMPORTANT THAN OBAMA
OFFICIALS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS WE
ARE SEEING NOW.
THE WHISTLEBLOWER ISSUE THE
PUSH TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS ON A CONTINUUM.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
MORE THAN THREE YEARS.
I THINK IT'S -- WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT I THINK IT'S MORE
THAN UNFAIRNESS.
I THINK WE ARE TESTING THE
PATIENCE OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
>> Tammy: YES.
AND WE CAN TAKE MARK ZAID AT
HIS WORD THAT HE USED THE
WORD COUP, RIGHT, GREGG?
>> HE DID BACK IN 2017.
>> Tammy: THEY HAVE NO SHAME
ABOUT THAT.
THEY ARE ALMOST PROUD OF IT.
THEY WERE STILL ON THE
TWITTER.
DIDN'T BOTHER TO DELETE
THEM.
AND THEN WE HAVE GOT THIS --
THE OTHER WHISTLEBLOWER'S --
SO-CALLED WHISTLEBLOWER
SENDING A CEASE AND DESIST
LETTER TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHAT IS THAT ALL ABOUT?
>> IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT TO
THE TWO LAWYERS WHO WROTE
IT.
I MEAN, CEASE AND DESIST
FROM EXERCISING YOUR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO DEFEND
YOURSELF TO REBUTT A FALSE
ACCUSATION AND THEY INSANELY
CITE THREE LAWS WITNESS
TAMPERING.
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T EVEN
KNOW WHO THE WITNESS IS.
YOU CAN'T TAMPER WITH A
WITNESS YOU HAVEN'T
IDENTIFIED.
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
NOTHING HAS BEEN OBSTRUCT
YOU HAD.
THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> AND FINALLY RETALIATION
AGAINST A WITNESS IF YOU
ACTUALLY READ THE STATUTE,
THE WITNESS HAS TO HAVE BEEN
KILLED OR HARMED ALREADY.
HE HASN'T BEEN.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
AMY
>>Y
>> Tammy: THEY SEEM TON
TRYING TO DECRIMINALIZE THE
SELF-DEFENSE.
THE ABILITY TO ENGAGE, AS
PRESIDENT, ONE OF THE
REASONS HE WAS ELECTED
AMERICAN PEOPLE NOTICED THAT
THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG.
THERE WAS SHENANIGANS THAT
THERE WAS MAYBE NOT THE RULE
OF LAW.
SET OF JUSTICE FOR PEOPLE IN
GENERAL.
TRUMP'S ELECTION ITSELF WAS
A STATEMENT AND A DESIRE
THAT WE WANTED THINGS TO BE
MORE CLEAR AND CONFRONTED.
HE IS DOING THAT AND AS I
HAVE NOTED THE IMPEACHMENT
THE EFFORT FOR IMPEACHMENT
IS ALMOST NECESSARY IF WE
WERE RIGHT IN 2016 THAT THIS
WAS INEVITABLE AND NOW WE
SEE HISTORIC LIVE THAT IT
SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN EXPECTED
AND ARRANGED FOR QUITE SOME